Marvel's defenders ended on a major
cliffhanger and simultaneously opened up
a huge storyline that we can expect to
see in daredevil season 3 yippee-ki-yay
movie lovers it's Jan here and today I'm
breaking down the defenders ending the
inspiration it takes from the comic book
storylines born again and predicting
what we can expect from new and existing
characters in the next season of
daredevil don't forget my defenders and
Punisher giveaway is also running on
this video so for a chance to win a cool
Funko pop all you have to do is leave a
comment about the series and subscribe
and in case you haven't seen it yet just
be aware there will be spoilers from the
defenders in this video at the end of
the defenders we see Matt lying injured
in a bed and we hear a nun tell someone
off-screen to get Maggie that name is
important because in the comics although
initially Matt didn't know his mother
became a nun called Margaret there was a
hint at this part of Matt's comic book
past in daredevil season 1 when stick
asked a nun at the orphanage if Matt's
mother was dead to which she replied
that is another story
thanks to season 1 of dirt devil we
already know about Matt's father the box
of battlin Jack Murdock who threw fight
some money but was bumped off when he
refused to continue doing so and in the
defenders Jessica Jones gives a handy
reminder of this element of Matt's
backstory when she and Matt talked to
the daughter of the Midland Circle
architect Jessica compares the
daughter's situation to Matt saying my
friend thought his dad had abandoned him
too but one day he learned the truth we
know that in season 1 before his final
fight Jack Murdock left a phone message
for his ex-wife asking her to look after
the young Matt though Matt ended up as
an orphanage but now in season 3 of the
show Matt looks set to finally learn the
truth about his mother and that part of
his past and the look of that final
scene in the defenders also points to
this notice how math is bandaged in bed
and how there's a cross above him a
bedside table and window either side of
him and the nun sitting by him all of
that is a clearer marsh to this image
from 1986 which appeared in daredevil
issue 230 in the born-again storyline by
Frank Miller and David Matt to Kelly in
fact defenders showrunner Marco Ramirez
has said that this is one of his
favorite dirt devil images from the
comics and he had it in mind to use in
the show from early on which is
interesting because in this issue Matt
is cared for by a nun named Maggie who
he later realizes
actually his mother the fact that Matt
survived the implosion of Midland Circle
at the end of the defenders reminded me
of something in season one of daredevil
that he said as a young boy to his
father about how Murdock's
take a lot of hits but they always get
back up now adults Matt may be on his
way to getting back up again after that
last explosive hit and the defenders but
given how important the born-again
storyline will be for season 3 of
daredevil there's going to be a whole
load more things to knock the devil of
Hell's Kitchen back off his feet again
for a start in that particular comic
book storyline Wilson Fisk finds out
daredevil secret identity and sets out
to destroy him during that time Matt
loses his home his job and very nearly
his life Fisk actually gets Matt's
information in directly due to Karen
Page who sold her knowledge of
Daredevils true identity for a drug fix
because in these comics page as a
heroin-addicted X actress turned porn
star so how much of this is going to
happen in daredevil season 3 well last
time we saw kingpin in season 2 he was
meeting with Matt in prison where he
attacked the lawyer and threatened to
wreck his and bogies live when he got
out later in his cell Fisk asked one of
his henchmen to get him Murdock's file
so he could ruin them and it seemed like
he might have already been connecting
the dots between Matt and daredevil
thanks to Matt punch in the prison and
Daredevils punch before Fisk was
arrested I expect season 3 to find
kingpin still out for revenge on Matt
and his former avocado at law and given
Fisk's wealth and connections it
wouldn't surprise me if he will soon
find himself out of prison and launching
a full-scale assault on Matt's life as
he already may have decisions about Matt
Murdock linked to daredevil it likely
won't take much to steer him in the
right direction perhaps even just to
Curless remark from someone indeed is
Karen page that desoky at the end of the
defenders about how stuck she was when
it came to writing her newspaper article
on the event if I reveal what happened
at Midland circle then all it takes is
someone like me figuring out superhero
and lawyer go missing at the same time
which brings me to Karen pages roll in
season 3 Paige has a very checkered
history in the comics and the TV show
has hinted at a complex background for
her in the MCU
she's obviously devastated by the fact
that Matt appears to have died so it's
not beyond belief that she could
turn to drug or drinks to numb her pain
then there's like newspaper clipping
about a mysterious accident that
possibly involved a young Karen for the
upcoming events of season 1 of The
Punisher either of which could also
drive Karen into a darker future I do
hope so that we don't see her live out
her born-again storyline in the
defenders verse in fact given that
Karen's moved into journalism on the
show and since we lost journalist Ben
Urich back in third-level season 1 in
season 3 I can see Karen taking on a
similar role to the one Urich has in the
born-again comics and something else
from the born-again story which could be
pretty cool to see on TV is when Wilson
Fisk orders a super-powered psychotic
mercenary nuke to be brought in to
attack daredevil we've seen the MCU
version of nuke already on Jessica Jones
series and the character of NYPD cop and
former Special Ops agent will Simpson
Simpson like his comics what counterpart
has been involved in a military program
that supplies and with pills to alter
his aggression stamina pain and
regenerative levels and he was last seen
in season 1 of Jessica Jones being
hauled away by dr. cosmic soldiers he's
likely still mentally unstable so
there's a chance you could see him
brought into the next season of
daredevil to be manipulated by Wilson
Fisk into attacking the devil of Hell's
Kitchen by the way in the comics Captain
America turns up during nukes part of
the story and while I don't see Chris
Evans making an appearance in Marvel's
Netflix show it's possible that another
former military man like the Punisher
might take on CAPS part in the story
instead the comics also show kingpin
trying to get at Matt Murdock by having
a violent patient set free from an
asylum and sent out into the world
dressed as daredevil to kill foggy I
wonder if he'll take the opportunity to
bring in bullseye a character who many
fans have been keen to see in the TV
series and who at one point also
pretended to be daredevil in the comics
after Matt Murdock lost his memory and
couldn't remember who he actually was
there's already been a couple of
possible Easter eggs to bullseye in
previous episodes in the Netflix show
and at the end as the defenders when
Karen sits alone in church there are two
numbers on the hymn board 143 and 142 in
the comics the second of those numbers
is an issue that does feature bullseye
but what's more intriguing is that if
you add those two numbers up you get 285
which is one of those issues that I
mentioned just before where bullseye
pretends
to be daredevil Charlie Cox has said
many times that he'd love to see
bullseye on the show though Deborah Ann
Woll and Elodie yung on so keen no doubt
because bullseye kills both Karen page
and Elektra in the comics
if bullseye does make an appearance so
who would you like to see cast in the
role let me know in the comments below
find way just before we get that final
shot of Matt still alive at the end of
the defenders there's a very interesting
shot of what looks like a daredevil
silhouette crouched on a rooftop against
a red lit Empire State Building in the
background as the camera pans round we
see that it's not Matt Murdock but Danny
Rand instead a hint iron fist taking on
the role of daredevil for a time in
looking after the people of Hell's
Kitchen in the comics iron fist
masqueraded as daredevil at one point in
order to prevent Matt Murdock secret
identity from being uncovered in the
Netflix shows perhaps Danny might do
this because he thinks daredevil has
died so he wants to step up which means
it's possible we could see iron fist in
daredevil season 3 for a short time
until Matt resurfaces especially if
Daredevils next season comes out before
iron fist season 2 and let's not forget
that Matt was buried under the rubble of
Midland Circle together with Elektra and
Madame Gao it's hard not to imagine
Elektra and Gao probably survived given
they've had the immortality substance
during defenders Elektra killed both
Alexandra and stick purging herself of
people who've been manipulating her into
being a weapon or tool for themselves
and by the end of the show she's clear
about who she really is saying she
doesn't care about good or evil but
wants to be with Matt forever I can't
help but think she'll be back in
daredevil season 3 as it's quite
possible that she was the one who pulled
Matt out from under the rubble with the
enhanced rank she now has after she was
resurrected as the Madame Gao it's
possible we saw the end of her story for
now and whether she comes back is
probably more dependent on whether
Marvel wants to keep using the hand as a
villain in the Netflix show or whether
that storyline is completely over now
what would you like to see happen in
Dirt Devil Season 3 and do you have any
theories on how Matt Murdock ended up in
that bed or about who else survived the
collapse of the Midland Circle building
be sure to leave a comment and subscribe
for a chance to win an awesome defenders
or Punisher Funko pop I'll announce the
winner on an upcoming video so turn on
your notifications to make sure
you get all my new videos the winner of
my last giveaway for an alien cognitive
funky pop is on screen right now if
that's used and sends me a message with
your details so I can send you the prize
and if you enjoyed this do hit that
thumbs up button in the meantime you can
also check out my defenders Easter eggs
and Punisher season 1 videos plus more
multiple videos by tapping the screen
right here thanks for watching and see
you next time you be gay movie lovers